enfin je voudrais pas trop trop en
parler de parler de caramel parce que
c'est le nom de la chatte devant oui
parce qu'il per pas
enombrageou c'est Monsieur ser c'est la
télévisionz attendez une
seconde qu'est-ce que c'est c'est c'est
3 milli d'amis vous savez on a
rendezvous avec Michel serro il est là
non monsieur n'est pas là
malheureusement mais comment c'est pas
vous mich moi c'estd qu'à C HECI à C
HECI voyez je suis obligé de manque de
personnel je m'occupe de la maison et ne
peut pas vous recevoir en tant que ah
bon mais dit donc alors attention là on
s'est trompé non non mais simplement euh
c'est pourquoi exactement écoutez on
fait un film sur Michel et 30 Millions
d'Amis vous savez ces animaux et cetera
vous voulez voir les animaux oui le F
est là bon vous êtes combien on est
quatre mais vous avez manger non parce
que je vous dis parce que quelquefis
quand on vient chez moi on vient les
journalistes de manger de boire et de
manger et quelque fois même de casser
alors est-ce que vous avez mangé déjà
nous on a mangé vous avez bu manger oui
bon pour la casse écoutz laaddion
écoutez vous allez vous allez entrer
doucement simplement je vous demanderai
de faire très attention parce que
effectivement nous avons deux animaux
bon les c'est c'est pas je ne peux pas
approcher parce que je ne peux pas le
dire j'ai un un énorme briillard oui qui
est très oui vindicatif enfin très
méchant bon écoute présenterement aucune
aucune réflexion devant le chien me
concernant ah bon parce qu'il il peut
très méchant
d'accord B ma femme ma fille et cetera
le personnel de la maison tout ça pouvez
dire à peu près ce que vous voulez mais
sur moi ne dites ni les uns ni les
autres ni monsieurs ne faites pas de
genre de réflexion déplaisante car vous
seriez mordu répondz de rien écoutez on
suit s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
monsieur
alons-y excusez-moi voyez je parce que
j'ai des heures j'ai des heures où o je
suis obligé de m'occuper de la maison
Entz non vous restez pardon vous n'avez
pas de personnel en ce moment euh non
qu'est-ce que vous vous voulez vous êtes
photographe monsieur entré vous êtes
abant alors vous êtes cinq entré
monsieur excusez-moi pas prévenu hein
pardon je ferme parce que c'est terminé
c'est terminé c'est complet pour le
moment s'il vous
plaîtd par ici faites attention ça
glisse nous avons eu énormément de neige
nous avons eu ici jusqu'à 1 M80 de neige
ces jour-ci c'est incroyable et dans
cette uniquement dans cette dans cette
portion de ne on sait pas ce qu'il y a
eu par ici monsieur
non alors simplement je vous
demanderai les plus â peut-être devant
non non les enfants làabord parce qu'il
fait pas de mal aux enfants du tout les
enfants vous avez y a des enfants parmi
vous n pas très très
vieux c'est le visage un peu bon
alors si vous voulez on va
attention
voil viens viens
regarde oh il est
[Musique]
méchant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui alors Michel il y a un serber
terrible qui nous a fait un barrage à la
je vous av vous avez pris vous avez vu
mon Vallé de chambre oui bah oui mais ça
remarqué là je suis là vous risquez rien
mais en principe enfin il est pas il est
pas ile alors il y a deux personnes sont
pas faciles dans la maison c'est le
céber et le chien et et lE CHIEN Le
chien oui présentez-nous le le candidat
écoutez vous voulez vous retourner
d'abord assayez-vous s'il vous plaît
assez-vous c'est Romulus il s'appelle
voilà un peu de poil mais ça on a
l'habitude alors assiez-toi assiez-toi
mais tu vas pas rester voilà donne
bonjour ben vous auriez dû vous mettre
de l'autre côté parce que voyez bon
c'est romelus un chat qui qui é avec
nous depuis ah il a il a 10 ans quand
même 10 ans quand même 10s oui Cain vous
l'aimez bien ah bah il fait partie de la
famille évidemment oui parce que c'est
un peu curieux c'est que on a l'habitude
d'aller tourner chez les acteurs ils ont
le côté copain je vais vous demander la
permission est-ce que je peux enlever
cette robe de chamb écoutez oui faites
comme ser quand même plus détendu parce
que là ça vraiment j'ai voulu vous faire
plaisir ça serait mieux avec de la
couleur mais je me sens un peu guindé là
comme ça pu lui il va pas changer de r
évidemment voilà c'est vrai par qu'on
peut pas être au théâtre toute la
journée voilà
oh est comme ça ah bien chez soi voilà
oui alors dites-moi ce qui m'étonne
beaucoup c'est que ce chien et il y a un
chat aussi dans la maison et on a
vraiment l'impression que ce sont des
des membres de la famille
oui bien sûr mais c'estàd qu'ils vivent
avec nous ils sont tout le temps là ils
sont pas des enfants quand même ils sont
des bêtes qu même ça reste des bêtes non
mais en vous dites à votre femme est-ce
que le chien est là je veux dire comme
un peu comme on dit est-ce que
margarette est rentrée en oui c'est ça
est-ce que oui Romulus a fait ces devoir
est-ce qu'il a bien mangé ce qui va bien
oui oui Michel qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui vous intéresse dans les gros chiens
vous aimez les gros chiens moi person
personellement j'aime mieux la la
présence d'un gros d'un gros chien je
trouve que ça
ou mais dans la maison par exemple c'est
bétant et cetera non ça vous pourquoi
vous savez ça non ça c'est comme les non
je trouve que la présence d'un gros
chien d'abord pour la la sécurité si
vous voulez là là et puis ça a l'air
d'un chien j'aime bien des les bêtes qui
sont pas trop trafiqué parce qu'il y a
des vous avez des chiens on sait plus
très bien ce que c'est si c'est une
machine à coudre un chien un chapeau de
avec des fleurs enfin on ne sait pas
très bien je veux dire par là euh on
arrive à une telle sélection je trouve
que et de fabrication c'est un peu comme
les roses alors je sais qu'on fait de
très belles roses t les mais enfin on
trafique un peu trop les chiens donc un
chien robuste vous savez le chien pour
moi c'est un peu comme la cuisine J'aime
les les plats netes solides oui mais
netes qui sont pas trop sophistiqués
alors euh les gros chiens en général et
et par exemple celui-ci il a des coins
dans la maison qui l'intéressent bah
vous savez vous devriez pas poser cette
question demand demandez-lui je crois
que c'est la cuisine qui l'intéresse
plus par exemple il vous regarde quand
vous arrivez il vous regarde à la
fenêtre ah bah oui ben naturellement il
guê oui oui et alors évidemment il ouvre
les portes aussi il fait des T chos oui
vousz ouvrir les portes ah oui il est
magnifique non ce qu'il faut alors il a
simplement il a un petit défaut ça je
dois le dire d'abord c'est un chien de
garde formidable ça c'est pas un défaut
mais il a un défaut
c'est je parle doucement parce qu'on
toujours l'impression qu' de temps en
temps il dans les yeux ah oui non mais
il comprend très bien il va peut-être
baisser la tête est-ce que tu voles
est-ce que vous volez Romulus ben oui
voyez alors là ça va être la demire de
beurre au trois steaks il y a quand même
une chose extraordinaire je veux dire ce
chien a un mare la journée et une
maîtresse le soir enfin si on peut dire
oui vous vous voulez parler du théâtre
oui oui bah oui mais il ne connaî pas
sous cet angle là voyez si je passe en
dans la cage au fol dans un extrait de
la cage au fol à ce moment-là il va être
très surpris parce qu'il va peut-être
reconnaître la voix mais autrement il
est très bon
spectateur tous les soirs depuis 5 ans
pour Michel cro c'est le même rituel
1800 représentation de la cage au
[Musique]
fol après un maquillage compliqué une
demi-heure plus tard la métamorphose est
réussie un personnage prend vie excessif
et haut en couleur
[Musique]
ditmoi parlez-moi un peu de ce chat
alors c'est un chat extrêmement distant
je dire il est très bien élevé il faut
pas l'ennuyer il vous dit bonjour quand
il en a
envie mais il est très mignon c'est une
chatte elle est très mignonne elle est
très belle et puis je l'aime bien parce
que elle mange elle s tenir à table je
veux
dire elle B pas non non mais non
seulement elle B pas mais je vous voulez
elle lui je ça m'embête de dire ça
devant lui mais il aurait tendance à
être un peu un peu goin enfin je veux
dire il mange il aime bien bon elle non
n'est-ce pas quand elle a pris un peu de
foie un peu de poisson n'est-ce pas Cho
on peut la sortir et elle est d'ailleurs
elle a une ligne magnifique vous la
verrez quand même j'espère avant votre
départ on va la voir enfin je voudrais
pas trop trop en parler de parler de de
caramel parce que c'est le nom de la
chatte VO devant euh ou parce qu'il pe
pas enombrage oui oui oui oui n'empêche
que je rentre tous les soirs euh tard
après en général je ne d pas avant de
jouer donc je dne tous les soirs vers 1h
du matin vous être seul je suis seul
enfin je suis seul non heureusement j'ai
mon chien et ma chatte sinon mon pauvre
monsieur vous vous rendez compte F en
face de mon
camber parce que c'est que le bout de
bid il y a rien rien à bouer pas qu'il
on
pas
dégueulass
merde casse pas la
tête c'est agréable ah oui une seconde
oui madame et monsieur
mer ça elle dort elle d toutes les trois
ça aucune importance s'en
fout second vous permettez oui chacun
son tour ah moutard pas aimé
çache ah est qu'est-ce que tu
veux vous aurez du fromage tout à
l'heure de fromage tout à l'heure vous
me laisserez lesécroûes comme
d'habitude
quoi les casse viens une seconde on
s'occupe de vous aussi ah dis donc
BIF il restera pas grand chose pour moi
allez agréable
[Musique]
oui voilà voilà alor a rien du tout
voilà la moutarde ça n intéresse pas il
y a plus rien il y a plus rien c'est
terminé ah dis
donc bon ben à cette heure-ci après une
journée pareille à faire un peu de repos
pour tout le
[Musique]
monde